[Music]
hey guys it's me jasmine and for the
next 14 days i'm gonna be trying the
surf food diet which is what adele
reportedly followed to achieve her
fitness goals others such as pippa
middleton conor mcgregor and david haye
have also been said to use this diet
i've been seeing this all over the
internet and the surf food diet in a
nutshell consists of a group of foods
called surf foods which are rich in
nutrients that supposedly help us boost
metabolism and activate fat burning
genes or what they're calling the skinny
gene so am i skeptical yes but can't
knock it till you try it there's a list
of top 20 syrup foods a few of which are
red wine chocolate strawberries i've
been over indulging during the holidays
with a lot of sweet treats and i'm
excited to see how this goes
it's day one and uh we're gonna start
our day off with the juice two handfuls
of kale a large handful of arugula a
very small handful of parsley i'm gonna
poop myself are you serious celery
apple
and ginger
last ingredient the lemon
swamp water time to taste the juice
oh it's pretty bad it's like savory sour
and peppery well this will be fun this
journey okay
oh my
so honestly it felt like it was off to a
bad start but then the first meal was
the asian shrimp stir-fry with buckwheat
noodles and it was not only delicious
but it was humongous oh
look at this isn't this a huge amount of
food i actually don't even eat this much
on a day-to-day basis everything took
less than 15 minutes to prepare it was
pretty much just throwing everything in
a pan and stir frying it which is super
easy and all these ingredients in this
dish are very accessible i would say
let's dig in
that's pretty good i'm not going to talk
about authenticity but taste wise i'm
very happy morning it is day two and uh
i'm feeling kind of restless i didn't
sleep that great last night but i'm
ready to start the day off strong with
my laxative
i'll get used to it so day two woke up
feeling a little restless but i
continued with the program i had my
juices then i made my main meal i had a
stir-fried pork fillet with kale and
walnuts this does not taste like diet
food it tastes like a real meal that is
like very filling and flavorful i think
i'll take back what i said i'm not a fan
of the buckwheat the turmeric is just so
heavy and it makes it taste like what
you think
a health bowl from la would taste like
like dirt but the kale and pork are
really good my mood is literally
determined by food so i knew that i
would be somewhat grumpy until i had a
meal i liked again so after my first
couple juices of the day i made my main
meal of the day which was an aromatic
chicken breast with kale and red onions
and a tomato chili salsa while i was
making that i was getting super excited
because it was smelling so good the
colors were beautiful it just looked
really appetizing but next to me was my
boyfriend's seafood pasta made with lots
of heavy cream and that just looked a
little better but i ate it it was
delicious very filling and even my
boyfriend who doesn't like healthy
tasting foods enjoyed it
hmm
that's good yeah i would like buy this
at a restaurant really for a cafeteria
yeah
okay i wouldn't go that far good morning
it's day four going to start off with
another green juice this is the start of
my great day the syrup muesli was so
good i subbed the bug wheat flakes and
puffs with muesli mix some coconut
flakes medjool dates walnuts cocoa nibs
strawberries and greek yogurt i mixed it
all up and let it rest for 10 minutes
and it was ready to eat mmm this is the
best one so far out of any meal it
tasted like a health bowl that you get
from like newport beach while you walk
along the nearby promenade i'm a little
skeptical that this could make me lose
weight
then dinner was gourmet all right time
to make meal number two for today the
pan fried salmon fillet with caramelized
endive
on db arugula and celery leaf salad i
didn't get any celery leaf because i
want to wash it
place the parsley lemon juice capers
garlic and two teaspoons of the oil in a
food processor or blender and blend
until sweet this is what the sauce looks
like once it's blended smooth honestly
one of my favorite salads of all time it
tasted like it came from a fancy
mediterranean restaurant totally changed
my mind about capers also this recipe
calls for brown sugar and i think just
hearing the word sugar cheered me up
this is the
oh my god i'm not even exaggerating that
brown sugar glaze
i've never been on a diet where a recipe
called for sugar and i think that just
knowing the diet is about inclusion and
not exclusion just makes me feel a lot
less restricted and that lifted a lot of
the pressure
i would totally eat this every day this
is
freaking delicious another day another
juice day five i was already on another
high just because the meal from the
night before was so good and then the
certain muesli was good dinner was good
too so i was already excited i slept
really well last night i'm very happy
about it i woke up with a lot of energy
and in a really good mood i'm not groggy
at all i actually dreamt about the
salmon salad last night because
and then i got excited again because i
knew another meal with some asian
flavors were approaching today's recipe
calls for mirin it's pretty much like
sugar and rice wine i can't even believe
i can use this asian food is my comfort
food and in my past diets it often
involved making bland tasteless foods
that were clearly uninspired and frankly
just quite depressing the fact that i'm
able to have culturally diverse meals
that fit my flavor palette means a lot
to me like why would i continue to eat a
diet with food i hate honestly the old
me would probably just do it just to see
the number on the scale drop but now i'm
refusing to do that because my mindset
is shifted and i've learned that having
a diet that i enjoy has a positive
impact on my mental health so while i
was cooking i got really hungry i
cheated on my diet by eating an avocado
which i'm not sorry about
it's an avocado
hmm
this is real food i'm not even jealous
of your steak
what i'm really liking about this is
that in other diets i've done obviously
you have to cut down a lot on carbs and
this one you are but when i'm eating
this meal i feel like it's going to be
filling because i get an actual serving
of carbs i'm not saying go and cheat on
your diets but if you need a snack to
keep yourself sane during a diet then
who cares then later before bed i
cheated again but it was a banana
i don't feel bad though
good morning guys it is day six and i am
not gonna make a juice today i'm just
gonna blend it you guys probably think
that's really gross i mean it's not
pleasant but the only reason i'm doing
this is because i don't really want to
wash the juicer it takes like 20 minutes
to wash and like i'm just too busy
here goes
definitely much thicker
i should have washed the juicer i'm
having my first meal of the day this is
the cert super salad it took me like 40
minutes to prepare and i had all my
veggies prepped already so it did take a
little bit of time but it looks really
good and i'm ready to dig in
the more you chew the more the flavor
develops very refreshing the diet is
already so much easier to try out now
because at buzzfeed you're constantly
being tempted at the office by cupcakes
cookies chips the food from tasty shoots
but my boyfriend has the fastest
metabolism and he's constantly trying to
gain weight so he eats whatever he wants
and is able to stay lean and because of
that i'm always tempted at home too he
is enjoying some spinach artichoke dip
which i love
hey guys it's day seven of course
starting my morning off with the green
juice i did weigh myself this morning
and i am not seven pounds down i am five
pounds down officially seven pounds in
seven days didn't
necessarily pan out for me but i'm fine
with it i'm okay um
yeah i feel really good mentally like i
don't know i love myself it's better to
love myself more than it is to lose that
weight day seven's meal one which is a
cert food omelette and it called for
endeavor leaves but i ran out so i just
used kale and actually the omelet called
for bacon isn't that just wild eggs i
just threw them together a few eggs
added the kale and the bacon and some
parsley i also ran out of parsley so
i've been using my dry parsley but this
looks not bad let's try it
this is a pretty decent omelette you
know what's weird i don't even really
like bacon that much but when i'm on a
diet i'll take it duh
it is day one of phase two which means
it is day eight of this diet i'm pretty
excited about entering phase two because
we're not focusing on calorie counting
anymore and we get one juice
and three meals and one to two optional
syrup food
so my first meal today is the syrup food
smoothie i'm actually gonna meal prep
this because i looked up my calendar i'm
much busier this week than i was last
week i think the hardest part about
following these diets is that you know
it comes with a lot of cooking so i feel
like someone who has kids pets a busy
schedule in general this would be very
difficult for them but with meal prep
of course things can be much easier
some medjool dates these are great
sweeteners oh my strawberries
yum and
chocolate okay so for four smoothies
meal prepped i'm gonna need this much
chocolate
breakfast for the next three days is
done
[Music]
yeah it's not bad it's not good but it's
not bad i was feeling stressed earlier
from all this meal prepping but now that
it's done a lot of stress has been
lifted off my shoulders i made three
salads i just put all the dry
ingredients in there so it stays fresh
now time to prep my next three dinners
which will be the prawn arabiata with
buckwheat pasta so far the prana
arabiana has been very easy to put
together just threw in all the
vegetables and then two tins of tomatoes
and then i just need to cover this and
let it simmer
look at that
does that look like diet food dinner for
the next three nights are done doesn't
that look so good
i think this takes the cake so far i
could totally see myself making this
without making any adjustments to the
recipe for this recipe i would give it a
10 out of 10. these 9 and 10 were really
easy i think it's helpful to know that i
meal prepped for three days and that
they were all meals that i were decently
pleased with so i wasn't dreading any of
my meals and because i was making sure
to finish eating by 7pm it kind of felt
like i was constantly eating though i
did get munchies while watching tv late
at night
we are playing among us and i already
have my meal prep so i'm happily
enjoying it right now with my friends
the second week has already been so
smooth sailing with all the delicious
food and then i made probably the most
surprising thing that you could eat on a
diet pancakes to make pancake batter
place all the ingredients apart from the
olive oil in a blender and blend until
you have a smooth batter it should not
be too thick or too runny made half a
serving since i knew most of the serving
sizes have been quite large and then i
stored the rest of the batter in the
fridge since it was good for up to five
days
day 14 the last day i wanted to go big i
still had leftover pancake batter and
miso soup so i just had that for
breakfast and lunch and for dinner
i made a pizza
making the sauce
got my beautiful dough baby over here
and we're just gonna cover it up and let
it rise for about an hour
i'm gonna try and
spin this
i'm doing it mozzarella i'm going a
little heavy but it's the last day of
the diet okay all right i'm having a
vegetarian pizza today so i'm just gonna
top it with some grilled eggplant more
the merrier
it's ready to go into the oven
i added some basil to the top of the
pizza i think it's the perfect touch i'm
super excited to try this cheers
it's not bad at all wow
one thing i'll change more cheese
it's crazy to even believe that this
diet is over but i think it went very
well if i were to try this diet while
not in a pandemic i think it would have
gone a very different way so let's just
get to it did i lose weight yes i lost
five pounds in the first seven days then
another two pounds in the second week
for a total of seven pounds in 14 days
i'm very happy with these results i
probably won't be continuing as strictly
as i was over the past couple of weeks
but i learned a lot about myself i
strengthened my positive relationship
with food and will a thousand percent
happily be making more of these recipes
it's all about good food for me honestly
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you